Datastore is a database that runs in the Google
Cloud, and it's available to any App Engine application.
As you already heard, it is built on big
table, which is used by many of the huge services
being run at Google. So, that also gives datastore
unlimited scalability. Please see the instructor comments for more
information on big table. Datastore is a no SQL
database and to be more specific, it is a key-value,
column-oriented store. It is key-value because the way
you get and put the information, is very
similar to that of hash tables or associative
arrays in programming languages. And it's column-oriented which
means that columns, not rows, are stored together,
which means better performance and scalability for certain
operations. This also means that Datastore is not
like a traditional relational database system using SQL.
The design of Datastore allows you to create applications
operating at Google scale. And by that, we mean
that your application can scale indefinitely, using distribution in
the same way as many of the very big
Google services do. This means that your data is
not only stored on one computer or file system,
but on multiple ones. Even in separate data centers,
these type of distribution increases performance as you can retrieve
data from these locations in parallel. Your application does
not need to do anything extra to get all of
this value. This is one of the great benefits using
Datastore. You don't have to think about it, because Datastore
automatically manages the scalability. However, this also means that you
need to design your data model to take advantage of
this. And when the data is stored in multiple locations,
you also replicate the data. This means, you can always
rely on that data being available. Because even if there is a failure somewhere,
for example, a disk fails or lightning strikes and destroys a data center. That
data is always available from another location.
So with the design of data storage,
you get both scalability and availability without
having to do anything. It's quite amazing.